look at Titanic's there's a new iceberg
in town this massive hunk of frozen
water broke off the Larsen Sea ice shelf
in Antarctica is now loose on the open
sea where it'll be on by birds and
threatened shipping lanes until it melts
as it's private in a way Americans can't
even understand this is 7 New York
City's 7 New York City think about how
much urine that is 7 New York City's of
urine that is what Larsen C means from
the environment for some reason people
seem freaked out about this Delaware
sized iceberg barreling across the ocean
and there's nothing we can do to stop it
from coming into our houses and sinking
all of our Titanic's or melting and
raising sea levels worldwide not to
mention all the devastating habitat
change and potentially climate changes
that will ensue after that the
environmental just implode and then
we're all going to die but that's
probably path that's why I have my new
years anyway so what about it anyway
comedians I would like you to say
something to calm everyone down about
the Larsen C iceberg come on we just
want to reconnect with his pops Ice Cube
right yeah boys ginger I'm first of all
thank news coming right and secondly we
don't need to worry cuz now we're all
going to live in our favorite movie
okay he was at the mermaid or something
okay well we just have to look on the
bright side and maybe we'll get another
Celine Dion hit out of this yeah
[Applause]